merci merci mesdames et messieurs
bonjour chers québécois chaque québécois
j'annonce aujourd'hui que je mets fin à
ma carrière politique
j'ai informé le président du parti
libéral du québec de la démission à
titre de chef de parti
le caucus des députés choisira sous peu
un chef intérimaire puis deux instances
planifieront la tenue d'une course à la
direction au moment jugé le plus
important je ne commencerai pas non plus
mon mandat de député de roberval je
remercie encore une fois mes
concitoyennes et concitoyens pour leur
soutien pendant donc tenir une élection
partielle dans la circonscription dans
les délais prévus par la loi
je présenterai bien sûr la démission au
lieutenant gouverneur afin d'assurer la
transition la plus harmonieuse possible
le résultat sans équivoque de
d'élections générales
après un mandat pourtant marqué par un
redressement et une relance historique
du québec mène à prendre cette décision
le désir de changement s'est clairement
exprimé il faut donc en assumer les
conséquences
une nouvelle personne peut-être même une
nouvelle génération
si les militants décident l'hydre à la
prochaine étape de la vie de notre grand
parti
j'ai été très fier de représenter le
comté de roberval la région du
saguenay-lac-saint-jean et 10 basé mon
action politique
fière aussi d'avoir été un premier
ministre deux régions habitants en zone
rurale auprès d'agriculteurs de forêt si
l'entrepreneur à proximité d'une
communauté autochtone ma fonction m'a
permis je crois de faire en sorte que ma
région que les régions à reçoivent les
fruits et les bénéfices ont été
appréciable je crois que c'est ce que
les électeurs ont voulu reconnaître à me
renouveler leur confiance le 1er octobre
je les remercie de leur amitié et de
leur soutien
j'ai été tellement fiers de parler
d'elle et de partout au québec au canada
et l'allemand
je crois j'espère qu'ils comprendront ma
décision dans les circonstances
avec un bilan plus qu'enviable et de
résultats d'élections du 1er octobre
après avoir mis toute mon énergie au
service du québec demeurer en politique
à quelques titres que ce soit est au
delà de ce que je me sens humainement
capable de faire je demande aux
québécoises et aux québécois de le
comprendre et de me laisser prendre
congé en paix au total j'aurais consacré
près de dix ans de ma vie au service
public se soit toujours pour moi une
grande source de fierté
je veux prendre un moment pour remercier
les femmes et les hommes qui se sont
engagés en politique à mes côtés compris
celles et ceux qui ont été défaits le
1er octobre l'équipe formidable de
députés qui ont rendu possible tout ce
qu'on a accompli dans les quatre
dernières années
ce fut un honneur d'être leur chef
celles et ceux qui ont fait vivre nos
bureaux de circonscription no cabinet au
cours du mandat qui vient de se terminer
aussi tous les militants les bénévoles
et l'équipe de la permanence du parti
libéral du québec
sans elle sans eux un parti politique ne
peut pas vivre durée et grandir un grand
merci aussi à notre remarquable fonction
publique travailler quotidiennement avec
ces femmes et ces hommes de grande
qualité avait été pour moi une source
d'inspiration et d'apprentissage
prenons-en grand soin comme lady le 1er
octobre je laisse le québec dans un bien
meilleur état que celui dans lequel je
les trouvais en 2014 entre avril 2014 et
octobre 2018 le changement est profond
nos finances sont solidement équilibrer
le poids de la dette est en baisse
l'économie tourne à plein régime
un nombre d'emplois record a été créé
nos moyens retrouver nous permettre de
bien financer nos services publics
particulièrement l'éducation notre grand
projet de société sur la base d'une
vision ambitieuse de réussite pour tous
aujourd'hui plus de 3000 personnes de
plus en oeuvre dans nos écoles
1500 personnes de plus en soins à
domicile et 2002 plus en soit prolongée
plus d'un million de québécoises et
québécois de plus ont accès à un médecin
de famille
dans les faits la pauvreté a reculé mais
est toujours présente de nombreuses
stratégies innovantes sont en place un
plan de lutte à la pauvreté une
politique culturelle renouveler une
stratégie numérique
oui nous avons été le gouvernement de
l'économie et des finances bien géré et
bien plus encore nous avons tenu un
nombre record d'engagement agi pour
l'équité entre les générations reconnu
les gouvernements de proximité et
l'insularité des îles de la madeleine
le québec est le leader canadien dans la
lutte aux changements climatiques
le québec à sa première stratégie
maritime nous avons sauvé l'île
d'anticosti de la dévastation à laquelle
d'autres la de sièges toutes nos régions
se porte mieux
toutes nos régions se porte mieux car
2014 maintenant une meilleure voire et
plus de lignes avec le parlement ce
quart très bien financées avec un
ministre est dédié à leurs intérêts car
nous sommes tous des québécois de
première classe
j'aimerais qu'ils sachent j'aimerais que
vous sachiez que je n'ai pas fait cela
pour des raisons électoralistes à court
terme mais parce que je crois
profondément à québec inclusif avec mon
équipe va donner les moyens de ses
ambitions et de l'avoir fait avancer
plus loin vers sa destination
un québec prospère instruit équitable et
vers le chemin est tracé
il reste bien sûr beaucoup à faire
faisons en sorte que le québec demeure
la société la plus équitable d'amérique
et plus continuer son développement de
façon durable faut rester engagés dans
la lutte aux changements climatiques
pour poursuivre la lutte contre la
pauvreté les moyens sont là la politique
culturelle renouveler doit être déployée
au profit de nos créateurs et de leur
public partout sur le territoire
nous devons continuer à faire progresser
notre influence dans le monde notamment
dans la francophonie
je souhaite connaître rhénans se
poursuivre au cours des prochaines
années
et souvenons nous qu'il est fragile
notre plus grand défi damas la
démographie et la pénurie sévère de main
d'oeuvre qui touchent toutes nos régions
dans cette circonstance autres la
formation
l'automatisation et la pleine
participation au marché du travail le
maintien de la cohésion sociale et du
caractère inclusif de notre société
devient encore plus important les
nouveaux arrivants qui combleront
beaucoup d'emplois disponibles ne
représente pas une menace pour notre
caractère distinct en amérique au
contraire chacune et chacun constitue un
actif essentiel à notre croissance à
nous à nous tous de faire en sorte
qu'ils s'intègrent bien à la société
québécoise
partout sur le territoire à cet effet
chaque mot chaque geste compte
dans un sens ou dans l'autre il faut
impérativement continuer à faire évoluer
notre relation de nation à nation avec
les premières nations et des inuits la
déclaration des nations unies doit
constituer la base de notre travail
ces peuples dont nous occupons les
territoires traditionnels doivent
détenir peut même les leviers de leur
développement et ont retiré le juste
part des bénéfices suzanne et moi allons
entreprendre une nouvelle phase de
l'aude hui tu sais le dire aujourd'hui
où elle nous mènera vers de nouveaux
défis passionnants j'espère certainement
vers plus de quiétude et de sérénité des
contacts réguliers avec ma mère nos
enfants et nos petits enfants
je la remercie encore pour sa générosité
son amour si souvent démontré aussi
aussi pour son écoute sa connaissance
très fine et personnels de la vraie vie
du vrai monde comme on dit chez nous il
est maintenant temps de penser un peu à
nous comme dit la chanson de la chanson
pardon je veux terminer cette
déclaration en vous parlant de nos
libertés
au cours de nos 400 ans d'histoire nous
avons défendu parfois jusqu'au sacrifice
ultime
elles sont contenues dans les chartes
québécoise et canadienne des droits et
libertés
elles sont précieuses donc fragile
prenons-en grand soin voici une belle
phrase domine manuf
à méditer à méditer pour toute société
et pour l'humanité dans son ensemble
le sort des minorités n'est pas un
dossier parmi d'autres il est avec le
sort des femmes
l'inde est révélateur les plus sûres de
l'avancement morale ou de la régression
le temps semblait nationale comme tous
les parm parlement se doit de protéger
leurs droits
plutôt que de les restreindre si elle
veut conserver sa légitimité
en fait c'est un de ses devoirs
principaux la majorité n'a pas tous les
droits
est ce qu'elles exercent doit être
compensé par la protection de ceux des
minorités
c'est un principe démocratique
fondamental le québec de demeurer une
terre d'accueil souriante une société
inclusive où toutes et tous sont invités
à la table un endroit où on juge les
humains pour ce qu'il y a dans leur tête
pas sur leurs têtes dans leur coeur pour
ce qu elle
ils ont à nous apporter je souhaite
qu'on nous admirent qu'on parle de nous
avant tout pour notre énergie créatrice
notre résilience nos artistes nos
savants et nos entrepreneurs
je demande à mon parti de rester fidèle
à ses valeurs et surtout de ne jamais
les marchandes et pour quelques votes
tenter d'imiter nos adversaires dans nos
cours durera pas à la victoire
la force de nos convictions oui ayons
confiance en nous le crayon surtout pas
l'autre ou l'avenir
écoutons notre belle jeunesse qui nous
dit de rester confiant et ouvert nous
avons toutes les raisons d'être
optimiste pour notre peuple je serai
toujours très fier avec mon équipe de
lui avoir fait faire un bout de chemin
au cours des dernières années à d'autres
maintenant pas d'autre maintenant de
prendre le relais vive le québec terre
française d'amérique territoires
immenses paysages magnifiques
si riche en ressources mais surtout en
pleine terre de mes ancêtres et des
nouveaux arrivants berceau des premières
nations et des blessures à soigner
terres fertiles d'espoir de résilience
et de liberté bonne journée facile
[Applaudissements]